que la partie comment ce que junior aime
plus que tout s'est joué au warm pool
avec ses amis t'es pas sérieux qui
compte vraiment jouer avec ça tu as
oublié d'enlever l'étiquette minutes
réalisé par le même studio que rio ait
l'âge de glace 4
je n'ai pas d'avis maman moi je veux
seulement qu'il mène il aimerait si je
savais bien joué au wall il fera tous
ont laissé impressionner qu'est ce que
tu dirais de sauter par dessus la sortie
de ben fallait malheureusement il
n'avait pas prévu et géré incident on
est où je crois qu'on est à la surface
c'est trop
mais qui es tu linda et toi tu es ce que
tu viens de vous montrer aussi junior et
ses amis vont devoir affronter le plus
méchant des méchants pour sauver leur
monde à table et soyez mes esclaves
attendez vous à vivre une grande
aventure chose que toi 2653 contre les
maux et à rencontrer le plus grand héros
de la terre dieu pleuré vraiment trop
cool disons plutôt le plus grand héros
sous la terre
je n'aurais jamais cru qu'un verre
puisse s'étirer haute avec merwan rim
dans le rôle de juniors et fabienne
carat dans celui de linda worms mais tu
es tout seul
oui je sais que je suis al je suis un
ver de terre le 7 octobre au cinéma